do you believe that you are
worthy of happiness when you don't
plan anything weeds grow
and that's how our mind works if we're
not clear about what we desire then we
can call in some really funky stuff
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the six
ways to manifest what you really want
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with way number
one be clear on what you really want
with gabby bernstein
the first type of manifestation is to
get very very clear
and you know if we're not clear about
what we desire then we can call in some
really funky stuff
yeah this is big and i just want to
interrupt you for a moment because like
one of the things that i say again and
again when i'm working with clients
i can help you get anything you want but
you have to tell me what that is
yeah that's it you know and the clarity
is really it's that secret key because
you're like a manifestation can opener
if somebody gets clear about what they
want that's really fun
that's your new name title manifestation
can't over yes
it's true because if somebody gets
really clear about what they want your
work is just releasing all the blocks
and all the disbelief yeah and so if
you're clear first and foremost you must
be clear yep
and and you must be clear because if you
are unclear you'll start to call in some
things that are
not really what you want you'll be
confused uh the other piece is that once
you're clear you can also then get clear
about all the ways that you don't
believe
all of the limiting beliefs all the
negativity that might be blocking you
way number two believe with oprah
winfrey
have you ever seen a mustard seed here i
have some here i want to pull one out
now jesus said if you had the faith of a
mustard seed
you could move mountains and anything
was possible
now i heard this as a kid and i really
believed it and so the question is what
do you believe
do you believe that you are worthy
of happiness do you believe that
happiness
success abundance comfort
fulfillment peace joy
love is a part of your birthright
is that what you believe or do you
believe something else
because you will manifest the life
that you believe way number three feed
your mind with positivity
with dan lok the universe in some way is
kind of a little bit rigged against us
that's correct let me prove to you
here's a garden
now when you plant roses what do you get
what do you get comment below you get
roses right
now what happens if you don't plan
anything and you don't take time
to even take care of the garden you
don't even pay attention to it
what happens weeds grow
so it is not the case that if you
don't plan something nothing will happen
no it's rather the case
when you don't plan anything weeds
grow and that's how our mind works so if
you're not
constantly feeding your mind i call that
mind feed
if you don't constantly feed your mind
with positive
motivation inspiration something
something that moves you towards your
goals practical useful
information to feed your mind you're not
doing that constantly
weeds grow and that's why personally i
don't watch news
because most news are nothing more than
negativity and they are just
designed to grab your attention right
the design is just sensations
it doesn't actually do much to your life
it doesn't add
value to your life it doesn't make you a
better person except it gets the heck
out of you
you watch enough news you don't even
want to go out right you don't want to
do anything
so i don't watch news if it's important
enough guess what
my team someone would tell me i'll
eventually find out but
most of the time i don't know what is
going on i focus on what i do
i want to protect this i want to protect
my filter i'm very very careful about
how i view the world and how i upgrade
my filter
and that's why law of attraction it
works all the time it works
24 7. you cannot stop it
even if you want to you cannot stop it
even if you're not paying attention to
it
so you could choose you can choose
what information you consume every
single day you can choose
what you pay attention to you can choose
what channel you watch
you can choose what videos you watch you
have
the power to choose hi this is dan lok i
want to share with you a
lesson from evan carmichael's new book
build
to serve this section is about making
money from your purpose
you have to embrace that if you never
learn how to make money from your
purpose
you always end up needing a day job and
your purpose will become
a hobby if that sounds like a great life
to you
then i'm happy for you if not then you
need to figure out a money-making model
that makes sense one that is consistent
one that is
significant one that can pay you so you
can quit your job and succeed
to the point where you are providing
jobs for others and helping
even more people you see money is
nothing more than a byproduct of
value creation the more people that you
serve the more successful that you will
be
so to have long-term success it's not
just built a lot
or built to sell or even build a skill
it is
built to serve and this book will teach
you exactly
how to do that way number four visualize
with bob proctor
everyone visualizes whether he realizes
it or not
visualization is one of the great
secrets of success
that's where we build a picture in our
mind when van gogh was asked
how do you do such beautiful work he
said i dream my painting
and then i paint my dream
well that's the way it works and all the
great leaders
have been great visionaries and
solomon said where there is no vision
the people will perish
now that doesn't mean they're going to
die it just means their results are
going to get weaker and weaker and
weaker and they're just not going to be
making it
happen the way they want to
everyone visualizes whether he realizes
it or not
visualization is a great secret to
success now look at this
the conscious use of this great power
attracts attracts to you
multiplied resources multiply it
attracts to you you know something about
the law of attraction
how do we attract well through
visualization
now look it and it intensifies your
wisdom
and enables you to make use of
advantages you formally fail to
recognize
way number five get rid of distractions
with satguru
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything it's organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in one direction
once you are like this anything that you
wish
happens without even lifting a little
finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want
if you organize these four dimensions
in one direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction it is like you want to travel
somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
it's very important that our physical
action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions
are controlled and properly directed if
it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive
right now that is our problem the
technology
which is supposed to make our life
beautiful and easy
has become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis
of our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible levels of
comfort and convenience to us
in the last 100 years or so
has also become a threat to our life
simply because
we are not conscious action we are in a
compulsive state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means
moving from a compulsive state of
activity
to a conscious state of activity and way
number six the last one before very
special bonus clip
is keep the vibration high with
dandapani
how do you feel after an interview do
you walk away and go like wow that was
really insightful i learned a lot this
is wonderful
take that same feeling and hold that
feeling in your mind
as you repeat that affirmation with a
visualization okay
creates a pattern in your subconscious
that starts to vibrate
at that frequency and you might have
interviewed hundreds of people and
there's some interviews that you go like
oh that wasn't that
great but there's some that you go like
this is probably one of my best
take the feeling from your best
interview and insert that into your
affirmation
because now it's going to be vibrating
at that feeling and then you'll start
attracting anything of a similar
vibration to it
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through compared to just 35
if you just got motivated but never
created a plan
and when you share your plan and have
accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through
so in the comments below write down your
single biggest takeaway as well as your
specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
whenever i get an idea i have to do
something immediately
trust your ideas believe that they're
amazing and and manifest them into the
world i love it i'm not
taking it from the approach of i want
this book to be a new york times
bestseller and i'm sitting there
visualizing my book being a new york
times bestseller i'm not visualizing
myself
being on brendan burchard's stage in
puerto rico to a couple thousand people
that's not the process that i typically
go through although i'm open to that
maybe being a mistake
i don't know it's never really felt like
it's worth it i don't know i'm sitting
there i've done it many times sitting
there visualizing i've never
really felt like that made a difference
i'm open to being
totally wrong but how i do apply it and
it's
massively seen an impact is as soon as i
get an idea for something
it's it's go time trust that vision that
came to you
trust that idea that's in your head and
do something immediately about it
when i thought about the idea of having
a house
of building a custom home i then went
off and built a 5 000 square foot custom
home
like inside of the year we had the whole
thing done when i thought about
silly things like i thought about having
a mannequin i was watching
green arrow on tv and i loved how they
all
had their their mannequins when they
were in their their lair or their realm
they had their outfits their costumes on
a mannequin and i thought
i feel like i'm i'm the green arrow i'm
i got the deep hood look i could be
this is this is the believe arrow right
uh
i want a mannequin too and then inside
of a week i had my own mannequin
here and so it may seem crazy mainstay
wild but that's how i
tend to operate and i think it's amazing
right now i'm thinking about doing a 30
day challenge on my youtube channel my
main youtube channel where every day for
the next 30 days
i have a series of videos to help you
build a better life so like 30 days to a
better life
and it's going to be some of our best
work
and i thought of the idea and now
immediately we're doing it and so
trust in the ideas that come to me and
then immediately creating them
and i guess manifesting them into the
world i am
a thousand percent all in on the
sitting and visualizing the thing that i
want
i have a struggle with and i'm open to
making it better and and being changed
where i face the hardest time with this
is my health so i broke my neck last
year right i wore this for
for 60 days taking it off for 10 minutes
a day
that was it and i had a concussion and i
had two spots in my neck that were
broken
and i did some meditation with a guy
named michael edwards who
led me to this guided meditation and he
helped me and he was doing it with me
in person over over the phone sending me
videos
and first off was getting the concussion
away because i'd never had a concussion
before and the meditation i found really
helped the concussion
the second part was the visualization so
i have a bone in the back of my neck
that broke off
so the big bone broke and it's healed
the little bone just kind of broke up
like the tip
like imagine i guess a fingernail kind
of hanging loose right
and it broke off and the doctor said
it's not going to come back together
and and it's not worth going and doing
surgery on it because
it's not a big deal don't worry about it
and
michael was convinced that i could heal
myself
and i could make that bone come back
together and so
every uh night and every morning i would
do it twice a day
meditating and visualizing the neck
coming back together and
and you know take some you know hand
sanitizer or
not hand sensitive take some lotion and
and you know put it on my neck and just
as i'm
to get more tactical like as i'm doing
it the the bones connecting
i talked to john assaraf who is a
another you know legendary expert in his
field and he's peacefully convinced that
he can come back together through
visualization through meditation
i haven't done it yet i haven't i
haven't i haven't cracked the code on
how to do it i wish i did
we did x-rays uh 60 days later and
it's still just as disconnected it still
just didn't move
a centimeter a millimeter closer and
that was honestly a little bit uh you
know
negative or low or defeating and and my
motivation to do it as intensely has
has waned i haven't been doing it twice
a day every day
i still want to believe that is possible
and i still kind of believe that it's
possible and maybe that's not enough
maybe that's the problem
uh maybe the problem was i never
believed enough that it could happen and
that's why it didn't happen
so i would i would love for that to work
i would love for
meditation to work i've meditated with
i don't know how many different people
so many different people i've never
really felt the benefit
um of having a meditation just feels
like i'm like i'm sitting down nothing
wrong with it just i don't feel extra
clarity or
anything coming out of the meditation so
i believe that it has worked for other
people
i believe that it can work for me i
haven't found the path to make it work
so that's where i'm still struggling and
trying to improve and trying to get
better and reaching out to experts and
why i still
feature people on my channel because i'm
trying to learn through the process as
well
but but the idea of taking the ideas
that do come to you and taking immediate
action on them
right the last letters of of law of
attraction is action doing something
trusting them i think a thousand percent
that can serve you it has served me i
know for sure can serve you
to learn to trust your ideas and do
something immediately
today about it and then build momentum
towards it and that big crazy thing that
you have in your mind may not even be
that big and crazy
once you actually start taking some
action on it and so that part i'm a
thousand percent down on and you need to
do something today in your life to
change
and the other side i'm totally open to
feedback suggestions on how
i can get better how you can get better
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
below me
or if you want to see bob proctor
explain the law of attraction
click the video right here next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there